مع حماية المزيد من الأمريكيين من
covid19 ، أظهرت دراسة جديدة للـ CDC أن لقاحات pfizer و
moderna تقلل
من خطر الاستشفاء بنسبة 94
بين البالغين الذين تم تطعيمهم بالكامل بعمر 65 عامًا أو
أكبر وقد يؤدي ذلك إلى عدد أقل من
حالات ما بعد الإصابة
والوفاة.
من
حالات الاستشفاء والوفيات
تتراجع ، كل ذلك نتيجة
التطعيم ،
يقول الدكتور أنتوني فوسي إنه لا يزال هناك
قدر كبير من العدوى في
الولايات المتحدة ،
لكن معدلات الإصابة بفيروس كوفيد 19 آخذة في الانخفاض
ويأمل المسؤولون أن
تحفز المزيد من الحوافز على التطعيمات الكاملة
المزيد من الأمريكيين للحصول على  لقاحاتهم
إذا ذهبنا أكثر بكثير مما
أعتقد أننا سنقوم بتطعيم المزيد من الناس ،
فعاجلاً وليس
آجلاً ستشهد المزيد من تحرير
الإرشادات ، وما زلنا
نواجه جدار التردد في لقاحات covid 19
وهذا صحيح  الآن جميع اللقاحات الثلاثة المستخدمة
في الولايات المتحدة لديها إذن للاستخدام في حالات الطوارئ
من إدارة
الأغذية والعقاقير يأمل fauci في الحصول على موافقة كاملة  البيضاوي
قريبًا ، آمل أن يفعلوا ذلك بسرعة لأنه
كما تقول
الناس عندما يسمعون أنه لا يزال
استخدامًا طارئًا ، لا يزال لديهم القليل من
القلق
بشأن المدى الذي يمكنك الذهاب إليه في
الدقيقة الصحية ، فأنا ماندي أذهب